this capsule we will be reducing the
gradient concept ten matches so one
has already said previously that one of
disadvantages of gross representation
pictures form a painting for dear
with a building every pixel it was
that could cost to the memory arts is
also one actually contained more
information that could we
interest so well in practice it
there is a lot of research that
still tries to work that this
representation there to try to
extract and find automatically
that she and extract it information
useful to extract from the picture had there is
other approaches that rather go
try to find by hand a
representation of the image that will
really only extract
relevant information for a
given application is what we will see
in this capsule it is an operation
which is often used to extract
different types of representations
image that are used in many
computer vision systems
then we will take as an example the
problem of extracting the outline of
shapes in an image
so if we had this image if of a 3
we could interest you in just
have the outline of 3 so only
have the information where are the
pixels that delineates the outline of the
character 3 that was drawn here so
a way to do that it could be
try to see which are among others
horizontal variations ie
what are the pixels or at each pixel
from how far does the
pixel value varies in this
direction is a way of doing things
that would be to see at each position
and j a pixel and see what is the
difference between the peak will be the position
rigid and its pixels just right so
at the position at the row eemeaa the
column
what's more I'm going to say and
the next annotation i'm going to call his
after
this table the capital H and here we have in
does the result of this calculation so by
example we have here the value of x ore g14
and the crown 15 months x then d 14 and
column 14 and so we actually see
that there are fairly high values ​​in
places like here or here
here also also here where there are
fairly high variations on an axis
horizontal
we prefer the same thing now on
the vertical axis and so in this case also
a position he lies in our table
20 in the vertical what we would calculate
that's the difference between the value in
the image at the row put there and the
column j - the word of pixel art
angeli and the column I have so the
variations in this direction love
so again we have values
high enough here then 6 here too
high value where actually we have a
peak holy wolf at this position there
in the vertical direction we have a
high variation in pixel intensity
so a first approach to extract
an account at the ca to be fair
consider that a pixel belongs to a
outline if the sum of the variations
horizontal and vertical is high but
no since the variation is signed in
does it bring us more than the
version be positive or negative
so what we're going to do is we're going
take the variation in watch variations
vertical for the square meter
we travel is also the variation
but on the horizontal axis then we will re
too much because also allowing the square
that makes it positive or negative
it is associated in reality
finally to normalize if we want one
can take square root is what we
will call
how but in our table here and j
have from this error there we
could just apply a threshold
so if they propose a threshold of 128
here we make sauce after someone
in our table 1 we see
that actually all the pixels that are
find approximately on the contour
of the form defined by my character 3
has a value that exceeds the threshold so
a value of 2.1 to what we
ask really wanted so because
that it's a pretty good job for
to detect the tale calmly and to all
its operations
what does that have to do with the notion
gradient that we saw when talking
of a function that we calculate and
partial derivatives and then putting them
to the rectors called this vector there the
gradient so why are we
is talking about a gradient image and well
the idea is actually that we can see this
calculation there as a kind of estimate
gradients on a function f is going to be
the function associated with the image that we
gives for a position a and b
what is the value of the intensity of the
pixel at this position there so
for example if we took our function
pictures here that gives us chicken pox at
position a and b are done this is the
drift and partial compared to b so
by definition our the hard life
partial function that would present
of parameters a and b are done by
ratio to b only that corresponds to the
limit
when we have a destiny a gap that tends
to zero of f2 a and b plus the difference - f2
ab divided by the size of the state and if
we take a delta equal to 1 of his
decides apprentices 6 me this calculation of
partial there after the delta equal to 1
we notice the similarity here we have
actually in place of more +1 daltons
here who lies in my advanced math
the equivalent of a and b here is so my
calculation of horizontal variations this is
a bit as partial said of this
image function there but relative to
the variable that corresponds to an index
of columns of the pixel in an image then
in the same way are made relative
to with delta equal to 1 we have this derby
partial there one could see have taken a
calculation approximations taking delta equal
at 1 and so finally looking at the
pixel right down so a row in
down in my picture
ok so for that reason we can
see the vertical variations and
horizontal as approximations of
the drift and partial of a function
picture in any position
yj and if we see h and v as a
calculating partial lifts in a
function images in a good image of
put them together like that in a
vector so at the position and j-jaures
two elements that would correspond the
first let's say the variations in total
second vertical variations so in
this table logis for his igis I would have
actually a vector and it's a
image gradient because here we had
actually making approximations of the
drift and partial of the function
images at the same time what is it
can do the gradient there since it's
a vector we could visualize it
then we are vector saint laurent park
to have fun visualizing this vector there
to each of the pixels in an image
given for example 6-2 bruno guigue
so we have a first image here with
a certain textures and for
different pixels we drew the
vector which corresponds gradient of
the image at this pixel here and here what we have
it's the same picture but with a
illumination with - illumination so
we can imagine that this image
it's the result of taking this picture
here but two
maybe in cast iron or with less
of light on the image not so we're going
to say that the picture -10 me nation in
does that here values ​​of pixels that
are closer to zero than here
first thing we can notice
is that the orientation ie
gradient language does not change between
both images
actually if we look for example
for example this gradient here here the same
gradient the same vector is here
notice his angle is exactly the
even
finally all that has changed is the
gradient standard so actually the
gradian here the vector it is longer
hanoi is more serious than the gradient here
so in this representation the
case have managed to factorize or
to distinguish the information on the
amount of illumination that is going
influence the names of the vectors the
language of the gradients and that she has a
son configuration of the structure or of
the shape finally of the image to a
given place so how much what
the pixels varies in this place of
the image
so that's going to be a calculation that will us
to distinguish these two
information there so what if by
example we're going to be a variant at the
amount of disposal for example if we
did object recognition the
quantity of appointments should not
change our ability to recognize a
object in an image the calculation of his
vectors there so the image gradients
will already allow us to illuminate
offense of eliminating information
on disposal for example taking
all vectors and normalize them
so years will ensure for all the same
no it's something we're going
explore later is a property
which is interesting that we will want
exploit for image gradients
so let's go a little more in detail
on commenting on what one calculates
image gradient there is what we will see
what we will be able to calculate from
an operation called the
two-dimensional correlation
so I could start by explaining
the operation of correlation by those
on board were commenting on what
calculates the horizontal and
vertical from a correlation so
a coloring of the dimensions between a
value table x1 the other table
double life this table actually we're going
call it a filter or a kernel and we're going
use for correlation the symbol
etoilists so the calculation of a
correlation that corresponds to taking
our filter here to position it to
all parties all positions
possible in the image so for example
you can position it here and
when we're cool, we'll do a
multiplication element by element
cofres 0 x 0 and there we would add the
amendment to the rules of the other
value in at the position of the film so
we would do more 255 x 10.5 + 0 x 10.5 which
is over 155 x 0 he would take
this value there and position it in
a table officials results years
delay
symbol it may be a star
no full canvas like that so they the
resulting value of this calculation at 0 x 0
255 30,500 points 5 255 x 0 it was
would position at the given location in the
result table of my correlation so
it means that this value if it is
calculated by doing this calculation there with the
filter at this position if this value
if we will rather be calculated at
position the filter like this here and if
so you are this value if it would be
calculated in positional
filter at this position
this is the case for all
possible positions for our filter w
in image x and that it corresponds to
calculations of a principle correlation
on the code to make a little more
explicit the definition of a
correlation
then we have a filter w that is us
given in one extract the size of the filter
in question is there all the positions
and j possible in my chart being my
picture on which I am a
correlation so we see that here we have a
iteration to the highest value
that can be achieved by taking into account
the height then the width of the
filter we take there under image so the
picture window in at the position
eligible and we multiply the winds
by mistake by our filter and then
finally we do the sum and are
placed in the table results of
our relationship will have here it's really
just to explicitly illustrate
that she is calculating a correlation
this says the calculation in python like that
these sails approach the most effective is
in fact a disadvantage of invoking
correlations of said like that is it
there are libraries that are in
able to do this calculation there so
very effective and among others it's even
possible to do this kind of calculation
very effectively using
graphics cards for example gpu and
finally one last operation
often sees in computer vision if
that of convolution in two
dimensions as its own symbol
mathematical this is actually this
operation there it's very similar the
correlation
the difference is that when we go
access the filters the point of
reference when computing indexes goes
be started in the last row and the
last column so for example his
venom calculate this element so in our
board
at that moment so we stop
reposition our filter here and in
this case also when we wanted to do the
calculation
the talent here we would have taken a
first value in teaching
of image or our title is positioned and
we compare them with morals
0-0 counting from this
cell so what are we going to do in
is that we will reverse the tidy
the columns so now the element
00 will be here the element so in
do I'm going to write it like this here so
normal reindeer 0-0 1-1 or six stopovers
mans 0-1 supplement 1 0 1 1 but with the
convolution to the fact it's going to be one
so that's going to be the row of
redheads it's going to be row 1
and if it's going to be column 06 it's going
to be the column so when we go
want to calculated with our son
positioned here we will multiply this
value there with the element 0-0 with our
age index that starts at this position
so that's going to be multiplied by
the zero here after that my 255 kidal
relative position 0.1 in my
bleeding can be compared with
the greens at position 0.01
here we have here then two alone
elements that will be found here so at the
position 1 0 will be compared with the
position 1 0 but with my big point of
reference therefore to his positions here and
finally this element so is going to be
doubled in one that is found
now here in the operation of
convulsions I tell myself piece 0 by 0.255
by 0.50 here by 251 loses 0.5 and 255 by
zero here and she manages the sum of everything
only that will give me one more 128
we notice the result in what 6 of
the convention is exactly the same as
the correlation so that's going to happen that
sometimes and that's due to the fact that I
even if I say as a point of reference
there in the rows the last column
it turns out that all my accesses a
disk gives the same result as I
start with the reference point here
or that I com
if they put in general it's not
necessarily one that no convolution
gave the same result as our
correlation this being said a relationship
between the two in fact we could more
lie as a convolution from a
code that we would have that will execute a
correlation and all we will have
case actually it went to our
correlation operation a new movie
but we reversed the order of
rows and one of the columns so we have
a version written in python here my
convolution could call my
correlation where I will take my filter w
and all I will do what for the
the first clue is 12th and say I
just take the basques
also the rows and in this case also
the columns so we can lift
think a little bit you'll see that
this is the ranking operation
reversed rows of columns and
also corresponds to use as
reference point the last element
row of last column sometimes the
result of a convolution is going to be the
same as the correlation is the case between
others if the filter is symmetrical
horizontally and vertically
so this is a condition that involves
that the convention will give the same
result that the correlation in
the previous example by cons
had a filter that was like that here
and in this case this chair not
symmetrical nor horizontally and
vertically however it is
that when we reverse
firstly the rows then the
columns we get the same leaves so
this condition also is not a
necessary condition for the
correlation in the same result
than the convolution hall but it's up to
because of the rate that is enough that's
a condition that is sufficient
for the eight-piece composition